I did not expect it honestly I'm
speechless
RuPaul got emotional following his Emmy
win for outstanding hosts for a reality
program on Sunday explaining to E teased
any direct Oh Y winning for drag race is
so incredibly special to him
it's very overwhelming and it's it's
just happened a few minutes ago so I'm
still in shock I'm I'm still not sure if
I'm dreaming or not honestly I mean in a
lot of ways this is a very historic win
how do you feel in this moment right now
besides emotions well I think about all
the kids who watch this show all of the
world who you know who finally have an
emotional navigation system this show
and the hundreds of girls have come
through our show have told their stories
so graciously and have really helped
young people around the world navigate
their lives and I think I'm the most
proud of that knowing the company you're
in Ryan Seacrest and Steve Harvey it's a
proud moment for you in your career I
assume and I admire all of those people
I know and I've been in this business
for almost 35 years and I know what it's
like to get to the point where all of
these nominees are and it's not easy
been a long journey for you to to this
moment right here it has been a very
long journey I've been doing this for a
long time and I've been very blessed and
I and that is not escape me I've had the
chance to get another bite of the Apple
so to speak I I you know hit it big
20-something years ago and went away and
I came back and and this is a quite a
prize moving forward you're going to be
known as Emmy award-winning host RuPaul
well I hadn't even thought about that
yeah
you
[Music]